democracia en riesgo en Perú es lo que
Argumenta el gobierno de Pedro Castillo
quien pidió a la Organización de Estados
Americanos medidas de urgencia para
abrir un diálogo entre los diversos
poderes del Estado me dirijo a usted con
la finalidad de solicitarle la
aplicación de los artículos 17 y 18 de
la carta democrática Interamericana
este mecanismo fue aprobado en 2001 para
fortalecer la institucionalidad
democrática de los Estados Americanos y
esto dice el artículo 17
podrá recurrir al secretario general o
al consejo permanente a fin de solicitar
asistencia para el fortalecimiento y
preservación de la institucionalidad
democrática pero el consejo
extraordinario de la oea para este
jueves fue convocado por el artículo 18
el secretario general o consejo
permanente podrá con el consentimiento
previo del gobierno afectado dispone de
visitas y otras gestiones con la
finalidad de hacer un análisis de la
situación y en caso necesario podrá
adoptar decisiones dirigidas a
participación de la institucionalidad
democrática y su fortalecimiento la
reunión se ha convocado con esta carta
en la que detallan la petición del
gobierno peruano las situaciones que en
el documento se detallan de acuerdo con
el gobierno peruano han configurado un
proceso destinado a la alteración del
orden e institucionalidad democrática
del Perú esto se produce después de que
la fiscalía hiciese una denuncia
constitucional por corrupción acusan a
Pedro castillo de ser el presunto líder
de una organización criminal en este
acervo probatorio de más de 190
elementos
sustentan detalladamente cada marco de
imputación Sin embargo la Constitución
no permite la imputación del presidente
por Ninguno de los cargos presentados